c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant une
interview quand jean-claude vous trouvez
pas que les jeunes acteurs ne respecte
plus assez leurs aînés ont respecté
c'est pas très amusant je préférais
qu'il les aime
vous trouvez pas que je suis pas de
votre temps les actrices s'habiller pas
tout comme des filles de petite vertu
aujourd'hui connu quand j'étais jeune
oui mais c'est bien petite vertu
dre pas qu'avant n'ai pas besoin
d'effets spéciaux pour rendre un film
spectaculaire
oui c'est vrai que quand on les enfants
du paradis les effets spéciaux c'était
prévert ouais je serai pas que les
spectateurs maintenant au cinéma ils ont
pu de manière aiguë du pop corn et si le
beauf à l'anthrax ah bah ouais c'est
vrai que c'est dommage de voir
disparaître toutes ses salles de cinéma
ah oui ça c'est triste
les multiplexes moi j'aime beaucoup les
petites salles ray c'est un souvenir
d'enfance quoi tout est pas qu'un cas
film en dvd ça remplacera jamais un film
dans une salle quand même à bâle à aller
au cinéma c'est une cérémonie avec une
fête
vous serez pas qu'avant les journalistes
qui respectait les acteurs il se prenait
pas pour des stars
non parce que j'ai connu un journaliste
important qui a dit du mal des enfants
du paradis
donc tout le monde peut se tromper ouais
vas lui on sait plus qui il est ouais je
veux pas que la télévision a tué le
cinéma finalement et qu'on sait pas
comment ça se terminera pour elle non
parce que la télévision fait des films
de télévision il ya une différence entre
les films de télévision et de cinéma
soit pas que le scénario actuellement
beaucoup moins d'intérêt quand même non
parce qu'il ya des gens qui cumulent
très très beau scénario vous savez j'ai
pas encore vu le film de chabrol mais je
vais y aller demain mais j'ai vu le
fauteuil d'orchestre et abu fume de
table danièle thompson a construit bien
écrit non je trouve dit triste un peu
aujourd'hui que les rôles secondaires
disparaissent ouais quand je suis arrivé
à de simbaya donc 50 ans pour moi
pauline carton jean tissier carette
d'agneau jules berry étaient des
vedettes
aujourd'hui il ya des vedettes il ya
moins d'acteurs irlandais
à oui non mais c'est pas les allées des
rôles secondaires
c'est une troupe mais art et il m'avait
dit leur hôtel du nord elle m'avait dit
le jouer et moi la tournée huit jours
dans hôtel du nord anna bella jean
pierre aumont cette semaine on se
souvienne qui s'éteint soit pas que le
cinéma est mort avec françois truffaut
non il a il était malade parce que quand
on serait parti il a manqué quelques uns
au cinéma mais il yad'autres françois
truffaut qui arrive que pas qu'une star
en jeans et une faute de goût quand même
pas une star qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
star moi j'aime beaucoup les légendes
j'ai connu par l'un des prix je dois
garbo elle faisait rêver parce qu'elles
savaient des déshabillés qui faisait
plus penser à beaucoup de choses qui
étaient plus érotique que de déchirer
blue jeans soit pas que la promo c'est
pénible en plus vous parler de sa vie
privée tout côte est avec vous mon cher
c'est un bonne or